it's always
um a huge honor to be a part of this
show to be in the building and obviously
hosting last year uh was was really
really special for me I mean when I when
you look at when you look at me growing
up as a kid that worship country music
and dreamed of being a part of country
music hosting the CMAs was a big big
deal for me and this year
um we obviously Peyton Manning's my
co-host and Peyton and I we've got a
good history together uh going on a
10-year friendship I mean he's very busy
and I'm very busy so we don't see each
other as much as we'd like but when we
do get together we really have a great
time and a lot of laughs and so it's
interesting you know you work with
Peyton or you're friends with him go
play golf but then we actually got to do
work together so it's interesting to
learn kind of how he goes about
his hosting Duty and learning kind of
what our chemistry will be but we're
excited and he and I are certainly
comfortable in the role and it should be
should be a lot of fun well you know
that we're still um you know we we've
done a couple of script reads and it's
where
um like we're kind of timing the jokes
and making sure they all they all go
well and then from there Peyton and I'll
put our little uh our little spin on
them my song that I'm performing is
country on it's my current single and
the first time I heard that song it just
kind of gave me like some throwback
Vibes of like 40 hour a week for a
living you know um the Alabama Song
and Country on really really just
showcases it's just got a lot of
patriotic feelings to it hey cowboy
just being able to stand on the stage at
CMAs and pay homage to
the hard-working men and women all
across this country and the hard-working
people that make this country what it is
and this song kind of kind of up
hopefully uplifts those people
[Music]